construite en 1166 par l'ordre religieux
de grands noms l'abbaye des moulineaux a
connu de nombreux propriétaires et
conflits avant de tomber en ruine en
1643 un lieu intrigant qui a inspiré
cécile dachary pour le projet aux
artistes le patrimoine du parc naturel
régional de la vallée de chevreuse mais
beaucoup à avoir un intérêt pour tous
kervin ça dégage toujours une une
ambiance est quelque chose de très
particulier il ya toujours une espèce de
nostalgie qui se dégage de ces endroits
là quand on visite une ruine
enfin moi en tout cas je ne peux pas
m'empêcher d'imaginer quelle était la
vie qui feint comment ça résonnait comme
on la vit résonnaient dans cet endroit
là à l'époque où il y avait des gens qui
vivaient traiter du fond du fantôme dans
ce cadre là c'est vraiment effectivement
c'est l'esprit de tous ces gens qui sont
passés là c'est tout ce qui flotte
encore et ça c'est un prime toujours les
lieux indéniablement couturière
céramistes photographes entre toutes ses
différentes casquettes
c'est donc celle de plasticienne que
cécile a décidé de porter pour ce projet
en créant une pièce à la signification
très particulière j'ai des signes de la
dentelle en fait avec mon petit la colle
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dessiner des
bâtiments j'ai fait une ville entière
comme ça au pistolet à colle c'est comme
si j'avais c'est comme si j'avais un
crayon en fait enfin je dessine vraiment
je dessine à malgré j'en profite je vais
faire une maquette dans cette technique
qui sera suspendu
dans les arbres devant un mur en ruine
qui reste aussi à distance comme un
fantôme vraiment de cette chapelle qui
reste au milieu des bois
c'est un matériau moderne entre
guillemets n'est pas très noble en fait
c'est pas si solide que ça non plus et
là c'est ce qui m'intéresse aussi dans
cette pièce qui va être suspendu pendant
trois semaines dans la forêt qui va être
laissés là et donc comme le thème est la
ruine
elle va peut-être se détruire là
peut-être pas résisté mais ça fait
partie du jeu c'est ce qui m'intéressait
aussi c'est donc après de nombreuses
heures de travail et près de 10 kg de
colle que cette installation nommée
poétique de la ruine sera ouverte au
public les 15 16 23 et 30 septembre dans
la forêt de poigne